Third time might be a charm, but a fourth entry is
just pushing it when it comes to some film series.
Look, "Terminator 3: Rise of the Machines"
can't touch the toes of its predecessors,
but it at least tries to tell a follow-up
story that many fans had pondered after
the conclusion of "Terminator 2:
Judgment Day." The critics agreed,
with the general consensus being it wasn't the
best film in the franchise but it was decent,
hence the 70% critical
approval on Rotten Tomatoes.
Then, "Terminator Salvation" arrived in 2009.
It boasts an all-star cast featuring Christian
Bale as John Connor and Sam Worthington as
the cyborg Marcus Wright. The film covers
the origin of the T-800 and how the unstoppable
Terminator came to be. Unfortunately, it also
has the distinction of being a "Terminator" film
without Arnold Schwarzenegger, which is basically
the equivalent of a Batman movie without the
Dark Knight. Fans weren't exactly thrilled that
Schwarzenegger's likeness was utilized, but
he failed to make an actual appearance here.
Even though this was the first "Terminator"
film to truly take the action to the dystopian
sci-fi future that everyone feared, there was
a massive disconnect between this installment,
the audience, and critics. This soft reboot
of the franchise was a monumental flop,
receiving only 33% critical
approval on Rotten Tomatoes
and making around $372 million at the
box office from a $200 million budget.
People can say what they want about the
first three "Transformers" films, but
they were pure money, making over $2.6 billion at
the global box office. That said, diehard fans of
the animated series and popular toys always wanted
the story to shift away from the human characters
to focus more on the bots and Cybertron's rich
lore. When it was clear that Shia LaBeouf wasn't
returning for "Transformers: Age of Extinction,"
and trailers showed off the Dinobots in action,
the audience had their fingers crossed that
the fourth movie might be something different.
In the end, "Transformers: Age of Extinction"
is essentially the same formula from before
with new human characters replacing the previous
archetypes. The story beats were the same. The
slow-motion scenes were the same. Heck, even the
love story was the same. If this film was made in
2023, it would feel as if someone asked ChatGPT to
make a "Transformers" film in the style of Michael
Bay. Despite the cookie-cutter approach, "Age of
Extinction" made over a billion dollars at the box
office, but it also received the lowest critical
and audience scores on Rotten Tomatoes until the
follow-up, "The Last Knight." Eventually, the
franchise was rebooted with 2018's "Bumblebee."
"That's a whole can of worms. There's
a million stories I could tell you."
"Superman 4: The Quest for Peace" is a study of
how a singular film can destroy one of the most
popular franchises in the world. By the time
this movie entered production, there wasn't
really a demand for it. "Superman 3" had seen
a drop in its earnings and critical reception,
indicating it might have been a good time
to wrap up the story as a trilogy. However,
The Cannon Group secured the rights to
Superman and convinced Christopher Reeve
to return as the Man of Steel for another
feature in which he had story input.
Speaking about working with Cannon
to the Los Angeles Times, Reeve said:
"They're like the guy who flies tourist
and wants first-class service. I admire
their recklessness in buying into
Superman, though they do like to
nickel-and-dime you on paper clips. But for
the most part, we're getting what we want."
Famously, "Superman 4" experienced a tumultuous
production, featuring budget cuts, cheap effects,
and entire scenes of the movie being
trimmed to keep down the costs. Mark Pillow,
who played Nuclear Man, explained to Yahoo
how most of his scenes were cut and how he
had a feeling all was not well. In the end,
the film was ravaged by fans and critics,
sentencing any potential Superman film to
the Phantom Zone for almost two decades.
"Home Alone 3" had the smarts to change
characters when it realized Macaulay Culkin
took a break from acting, and there was no
chance this feature would lure him out of
retirement. Was it as good as the previous
entries in the film series? No. But it
executes a similar premise under an original
guise and fans accepted it for what it was.
The made-for-TV "Home Alone 4: Taking Back
the House" thought it could capitalize on
the original series' popularity and return to
the adventures of Kevin McCallister and one of
his main foes, Marv, in a new flick.
Unfortunately, it recast both roles,
as Mike Weinberg and French Stewart replaced
Culkin and Daniel Stern respectively. Naturally,
fans were having none of it and
rejected the film out of principle.
What is even more insulting is how "Home Alone
4" tries to recreate the exact same gags from
the first two movies. Despite the negative
reaction and general disinterest in this movie,
it didn't stop filmmakers from soldiering
on and making further uninspired sequels.
"Keep the change, you filthy animal."
"The Matrix" has always been a peculiar franchise
in the sense that everyone loved the first film,
but the sequels weren't as universally
beloved upon release. They weren't hated,
but one would struggle to find someone
who listed "The Matrix Reloaded" or "The
Matrix Revolutions" as their favorite in the film
series. Nonetheless, they stood the test of time,
and most fans tend to look back on them more
fondly now since they wrapped up the story of Neo.
Considering the conclusive nature of the trilogy,
eyebrows were raised when it was announced a
fourth movie had entered production and would
see the return of Keanu Reeves and Carrie-Anne
Moss. There were questions. But of course,
fans would tune in to see what "The
Matrix Resurrections" was all about.
What followed was one of the most
divisive responses to a "Matrix"
film yet. While the critics gave it 63%
critical approval on Rotten Tomatoes,
audience members were left confused by
what they had seen. The film plays like
a meta-commentary on the previous films, while
it seemingly brings back these characters for
no good reason other than to continue the story.
"Resurrections" also bombed at the box office,
only making $157 million from a $190 million
budget. That said, there's a caveat in the
sense that the world was only emerging from the
coronavirus pandemic's haze, and Warner Bros.'
model of dropping cinema releases on HBO Max
on the same day didn't help box office numbers.
Indisputably, Jack Sparrow is the most
iconic character from the "Pirates of
the Caribbean" movies; however,
the operative word is "pirates"
here. A large part of the franchise's
success to that point had come due to
the supporting performances from Will Turner
and Elizabeth Swann. While Captain Jack might
have been the main face on the poster
and the character with the best lines,
Will and Elizabeth were the heartbeat of the story
and brought steadiness to the wild adventures.
The fourth movie, "On Stranger Tides,"
didn't feature either of them. In fact,
the two actors declined to return for the movie.
Speaking to The Independent, Kiera Knightley said,
"I said when I finished the trilogy that that was
going to be it. I had a wonderful time on it and
I met some extraordinary people but you know,
I think, for me, three is enough, definitely."
While "On Stranger Tides" did feature other
returning characters such as Captain Barbossa,
it simply lacks the gusto and appeal of the
previous films. The new cast members didn't
possess the chemistry of Will and Elizabeth,
and their absence was sorely felt here.
"I hate you."
By the time "Shrek the Third" released,
DreamWorks was pushing it. How many times
can an unfriendly ogre, his talking
donkey friend, and other fairy-tale
characters make us laugh until our insides
hurt? Well, the studio had the last laugh,
as the movie made over $800 million at the global
box office. Regardless of what anyone thought
of Shrek and its longevity as a franchise, the
families turned up in numbers to watch the movies.
As revealed by the screenwriter, the
original plan for "Shrek" was to end
it after five films. Though this
changed while the team made "Shrek
Forever After," believing it would end
the series on a more conclusive note.
While the fourth movie did introduce
new characters and different ogres,
it was clear the series was on its last legs and
stumbling around aimlessly. The jokes and premises
are repetitive, and the movie never feels like it
will surprise the audience in a positive way. All
things considered, it seemed like a wise choice
to end the film series there. However, nothing
is ever sacred in Hollywood, and there have
been talks of more "Shrek" films in the future.
Tim Burton redefined the possibilities of comic
book movies with the release of 1989's "Batman."
He showed how these superhero films could be more
than kid-friendly fodder. However, it was this
same devil-may-care attitude that resulted in
him getting the sack and being replaced by Joel
Schumacher for "Batman Forever" after his dark
aesthetic in "Batman Returns" failed to sell toys.
While it's generally accepted that "Batman
Forever" isn't as good as its predecessors,
the audiences still had fun with it and it
raked in over $330 million at the box office.
Expectedly, Schumacher was given the keys to
the Batcave for the sequel, "Batman & Robin."
The drama began when Val Kilmer decided he
didn't want to be Batman anymore and departed
the project, leaving the door open for George
Clooney to slip into the cape and cowl. However,
the biggest issue was not the change in actors;
instead, it was studio interference. After the
financial success of "Batman Forever," the toy
companies and other partners were interested
in making as much merchandise as possible out
of the film. This impacted the actual quality,
as it feels like one giant commercial. The fans
and critics saw right through it, and everyone
lambasted "Batman & Robin." It also killed
any potential Batman movies for eight years.
"This is why Superman works alone."
"The Karate Kid" franchise was built on the
chemistry and friendship of Daniel LaRusso
and Mister Miyagi. Even though Mr. Miyagi is no
longer part of the story in the current era due
to the passing of the actor, his influence
and invaluable lessons can be felt in "Cobra
Kai" as well. The first three "Karate Kid"
movies established and solidified this bond,
as Daniel and Mr. Miyagi helped each
other in their own unique way. Then,
a fourth film titled "The Next Karate
Kid" arrived in 1994 without Daniel.
Writing in his autobiography "Waxing
On: The Karate Kid and Me," actor
Ralph Macchio revealed he was never
asked to return for the film. In fact,
he found out the movie was happening
after reading about it in the paper.
In "The Next Karate Kid," Daniel is replaced by
Julie Pierce, played by Hilary Swank as the new
lead. Much like the story before, Mr. Miyagi
takes Julie under his wing and teaches her
karate. However, the audience and critics didn't
exactly take to this change in a positive manner,
blasting the derivative formula. While Swank's
performance was praised, the film stinks up
the franchise on Rotten Tomatoes with a 7%
critical approval rating and 24% audience score.
Instead of releasing "X-Men 4," 20th Century Fox
chose to focus on a prequel of the franchise's
most popular character: Wolverine. The
template for the story was already there
in the form of the comic book miniseries
"Origin." All the film would have to do
is lift from the source material and adapt
it to the big screen and throw in Wolverine.
While "X-Men Origins: Wolverine" takes influence
from the comics, it also veers off down a tangent
that didn't leave many viewers happy. For one, the
decision to make Sabretooth and Wolverine brothers
feels too much like a soap opera twist.
Second, Gambit is introduced in the film,
but he doesn't play nearly enough of
a major role. And finally, there's
Deadpool. By refusing to give the Merc with a
Mouth a costume and stitching his lips shut,
it takes away everything that made the character
popular to begin with. In the years since then,
Ryan Reynolds' "Deadpool" movies have poked fun at
how the character was treated in this adaptation.
There had been plans for a Magneto origin
film in the same vein as "X-Men Origins:
Wolverine." However, the
lukewarm reception towards
the film and average box office
performance put a pin in the idea.
"What are you doing?"
As an action-horror franchise, "Underworld"
strikes a fine balance between the frights
and thrilling spectacle. The third movie,
"Rise of the Lycans," acts as a prequel,
and only features the series' lead
Kate Beckinsale in a cameo at the
end. After having the missing story
blanks filled, fans were excited to
see Beckinsale return in full force as
Selene for 2012's "Underworld: Awakening."
Yet, all the excitement, frenetic energy, and
originality from before had been depleted by
the time the fourth movie arrived. Critics gave it
a shallow 25% approval rating on Rotten Tomatoes
and many were left questioning what was the
point of continuing the story if it was going
to be bland. Another sequel, "Underworld: Blood
Wars," dropped in 2016, but even that couldn't
give the film series the bite it needed
to get back on track to its glory days.